ah
[Música]
desde pequeña siempre tuve la ilusión de
conocer personas de todo el mundo sabía
que era un sueño bastante difícil de
realizar viviendo en montevideo ya que
si bien ha sido una ciudad construida en
gran parte por habitantes la diversidad
cultural no ha sido una de sus
características más fuertes en las
últimas décadas les pongo un ejemplo en
1998 yo tenía 16 años llevarlo y sido el
primer día de clase y veo unos
compañeros alrededor de una persona
entonces que alguien se había desmayado
o algo así entonces me acerco corriendo
pero no era un chico de dinamarca que
venía de intercambios seis meses y lo
estaban mirando prácticamente como si
fuera un extraterrestre
la cara de susto del chico era un poema
estoy segura que en ese momento lo único
que quería era tomarse el primer avión a
su casa y no volver jamás a mí también
me daba bastante curiosidad su presencia
pero bueno intenté ser un poco más
discreta que mis compañeros por suerte
con los días nos dimos cuenta de que era
un ser humano como nosotros y lo
integramos bastante bien pero bueno así
de difícil era ver un extranjero en
montevideo es por eso que unos años
después a los 21 decidirme españa con la
ilusión finalmente de hacer mi sueño
realidad fueron seis años muy intensos y
de mucho aprendizaje en 2009 vuelvo a
montevideo por un problema familiar y
decido quedarme finalmente ahí
uno de los cambios que más noté fue que
caminando por la calle sentía diferentes
acentos otros idiomas vestimentas más
coloridas pero sin embargo me da la
sensación de que los montevideanos aún
no lo notaban hace un par de años
hablando con un amigo sobre este tema él
me dijo que montevideo estaba muy lejos
de ser una ciudad cosmopolita entonces
para demostrarle lo contrario me propuse
un reto fotografiar en 100 días la mayor
cantidad de inmigrantes posibles tenía
que hacer un representante por país
josh a partir de una base de 8
extranjeros de ocho países diferentes
ellos fueron mis primeros modelos y
luego me contactaron con otros
inmigrantes me comuniqué con embajadas
consulados centros culturales y
afortunadamente tuve una respuesta muy
positiva de todos ellos lo cual me llevó
en esos 100 días a fotografiar personas
de 55 países diferentes abarcando los
cinco continentes
las fotografías eran sacadas en el lugar
favorito de cada persona en una manera
de que montevideo también estuviera
presente en el retrato nos conocíamos
así la sesión dura unos 20 minutos y por
suerte con la mayoría hubo tiempo para
una charla posterior
ellos no ven la ciudad gris y sombría
que vemos nosotros todo lo contrario ven
una ciudad llena de colores y de vida y
gracias a ellos ahora yo también la veo
así no solo me trasladaron a sus países
de origen sino que me ayudaron a
redescubrir mi propia ciudad
un año después se fue una experiencia
tan linda que retomé la serie esta vez
con la intención de llegar a los 100
países sabía que iba a ser un desafío
mucho más difícil de lograr entonces
subí el proyecto de las redes sociales
con la esperanza de que la gente le
gustará la idea y me ayudará a
terminarlo por suerte a la gente le
gustó esto de mostrar esta nueva cara de
montevideo y recibí muchos contactos de
personas que me pasaban países que yo no
tenía personas de países que yo no tenía
y así entre todos logramos
llegar a los 100 países lo que empezó
siendo un proyecto colectivo que
individual perdón terminó siendo algo
colectivo
montevideo crisol cultural es un
proyecto fotográfico de personas de 100
países de retratos de 52 mujeres y 48
hombres entre 18 y 92 años de edad y
parte del pse en siente a todos los
niveles socioeconómicos finalmente
montevideo vuelve a ser una ciudad que
recibe inmigrantes lamentablemente la
inmigración no está teniendo muy buena
prensa en el mundo y eso hace que genere
rechazo en mucha gente y el rechazo la
mayoría de las veces es producto del
miedo del miedo a lo desconocido a lo
diferente
estando en españa' tuve la suerte de
visitar varios países el viaje más
significativo que hice fue uno que
realicé por de marruecos senegal en
solitario y mayoritariamente a dedo
según mis amigos el ser mujer blanca de
24 años no era la mejor combinación para
hacer un viaje de estas características
te van a robar te van a violar te van a
matar era lo que más más repetían por
supuesto no les hice caso y me fui igual
llegando a senegal me entero que un
amigo estaba visitando a su familia en
dakar así que me invita a pasar unos
días con él en toda mi estadía en su
casa siempre estuve acompañada si no era
por él era por un amigo por un hermano
siempre con un hombre al lado al igual
que mis amigos en españa' él también
tenía miedo de que me sucediera algo en
su propia ciudad
el último día leyó que ella estaba
cansada de eso que yo había hecho un
viaje muy largo por mi cuenta que no
necesitaba estar con guardaespaldas todo
el tiempo así que le dije que me iba a
ir al centro solo con la promesa de
volver temprano para que no se
preocupara estoy todo el día en el
centro a la tardecita me tomó el autobús
muy convencida de que sabía el trayecto
de vuelta a los 15 minutos me doy cuenta
que no tenía idea dónde estaba en vez de
preguntarle al chofer me bajé no sé por
qué ya estaba anocheciendo e íbamos por
un barrio sin luz me bajo
y fue el único momento en todo el viaje
que realmente sentí miedo que pensé de
esta no salgo
la calle de mi amigo no tenía nombre era
la calle de la farmacia en una zona que
ya no recuerdo
tenía eso anotado en un papel y se lo
mostraba a toda persona que pasaba que
se cruzaba en mi camino la barrera
idiomática que tan exótica me había
aparecido hasta ese momento me estaba
jugando muy en contra cuando ya estaba
perdiendo las experiencias de salir de
esa con vida se me acercan dos niños les
muestro el papel y me toman de la mano y
me llevan hasta un hombre que dice saber
dónde queda la calle me dice que me
subiera a su moto que él me llevaba
hasta ahí
la verdad que no era como la mejor
opción pero está se ha estado bastante
jugada así que me subí sin pensarlo
mucho fueron 40 minutos o eso es lo que
me parece a mí en plena un viaje en
pleno silencio y oscuridad hasta que
finalmente reconozco la calle
me bajo le ruego que acepte el dinero
para la gasolina porque imagina será lo
mínimo que podría ser por él pero no
hubo caso no lo acepto dijo que para él
ayudarme era un deber no estoy recuerdo
en la cara de felicidad de esos dos
niños al subirme en la moto estaban
súper felices de haberme podido ayudar
entonces yo me pregunto
porque los inmigrantes que están
llegando a mi ciudad deberían ser
diferentes a esos dos niños y al hombre
que me ayudaron esta noche en dakar si
nos permitimos conocerlos como yo lo
hice con este proyecto fotográfico nos
daremos cuenta de que no representan una
amenaza para nosotros que el extranjero
no es un enemigo más bien todo lo
contrario vienen a enriquecernos a
renovarnos y hacemos dar cuenta en mi
caso por ejemplo que mi ciudad es mucho
más hermosa de lo que yo pensaba
en esta época de muros prejuicios y
discriminación tenemos una oportunidad
única de enfrentar este tema de una
manera diferente con una mentalidad más
abierta y sobre todo sin miedo
comencemos por darles la bienvenida y
ofrecerles nuestra ayuda porque es muy
probable que más de uno de ellos también
se sienta perdido en lo personal me pone
muy contenta saber que los jóvenes de
hoy no tienen que irse lejos para vivir
las experiencias que yo quería vivir
cuando me fui de montevideo a los 21
años porque hoy es posible dar la vuelta
al mundo sin salir de montevideo muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]
ah